be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
what's going on Rob this is guys and in
this video we are stepping back into the
cosmic side of the Marvel Universe for
our beyond Omega level video series and
we're going to discuss one of the most
powerful beings in the entirety of the
Marvel multiverse The Living Tribunal
now The Living Tribunal was created by
Stan Lee Amarista
Maurice sever and I always keep one to
say Maurice Stevenson Maurice Severn and
herb shrimp and made his first
appearance as strange tales number 157
in 1967 and in that first appearance the
Living Tribunal was not drawn very well
he looks kind of funky right he looks
kind of weird and he's not huge like I
expected letting Tribunal to be like
this larger-than-life thing like hey I'm
like Andre the Giant but skinny or gold
and I have three phases it's kind of
weird
under the giant you guys ever look him
up he's like a gentle giant who's like
the nicest guy ever until you pissed him
off he's like braun strowman right like
look at braun strowman's like dude that
guy is enormous but I bet he's like
amazing with kids he's like a great big
teddy bear when it comes to like dealing
with kids like he's like the nicest guy
ever and then you like take his beer out
of his hand and he's just like okay so
like it's on now but but in any event
and the first appears the learning
tribunal back in the strange tales
comics basically his idea was to destroy
the planet Earth and the reason why was
because a living tribunal believed that
the earth was really kind of a source
for like all this evil and things like
that now of course Doctor Strange
basically convinced the Living Tribunal
that there was good in the world and
ultimately the tribunal chose to spare
the earth when Doctor Strange
essentially said that as a sorcerer
supreme he can maintain balance in this
realm right so this ties into the
purpose of a Living Tribunal and is the
reason for his creation within the
Marvel continuity which is to serve as a
judge that existed since the beginning
of time and is committed to preserving
the cosmic balance of the multiverse now
in the event that a universe becomes
unstable the Living Tribunal judges that
universe and in acts punishment
typically in the form of the total
destruction of that reality which is
pretty heavy-handed but let me tribunal
is so judgemental like hey your views
are different from mine therefore you
are bad and I'm going to destroy your
universe like you do it's crazy
like I suppose I don't really like the
idea of like the modern-day definition
of judgemental right because that's
really what it is like if you don't like
what I like then that means you're
judgmental
no it just means I don't like what you
like like hey fun fact world not
everybody's going to like what you like
and it doesn't make them wrong it just
makes them different right it makes them
different from you which is not a bad
thing it's weird how people can
celebrate other people's differences so
long as the differences are not too
from their own it's it's it's intriguing
right people are interesting in the
modern day but the Living Tribunal is
comprised of three aspects each
represented by one of his three phases
right so equity vengeance and necessity
with reveries of the principles
underlying and informing the living
tribunals judgment and all three phases
must agree in order for the Living
Tribunal to act now one thing that makes
the Living Tribunal different than other
cosmic entities from the Marvel Universe
is that he exists on a multiversal level
instead of a universal level and what I
mean by that is since the Marvel
multiverse is made up of an infinite
number of distinctly different universes
a version of most of the cosmic entities
exist in each one of those universes so
there's a version of eternity in the
main Marvel Universe there's a version
of eternity in the ultimate universe and
so on and so forth the same with the
other entities like The Watcher and
Galactus but there's only one living
Tribunal in the entire multiverse and he
exists in a place called the star
chamber which seems to be a distinct
section of the multiverse that's not
part of any one particular universe but
basically serves as a living tribunals
base of operations and the courtroom
from which he passes his universal
judgement fun fact it's also the place
where the Living Tribunal watches the
Golden Girls the problem with this that
the Living Tribunal has been very very
angry because he went to turn on the
Golden Girls one day and he was told
this show is not available in your
geographical location he was geo lot
from watching the Golden Girls but he
found a way to get around it and when
you're asking the question how it was
that he did that it's because a living
tribunal used surf shark VPN hashtag
sponsored video so if you guys are
anything like the living tribe you know
you guys like to watch your favorite TV
shows while you're traveling right but
the problem is that streaming libraries
in different locations can all change
based on where it is that you're at so
search shark lets you access more than a
dozen different Netflix as well as other
entertainment libraries such as hulu
amazon prime HBO and many many more in
addition to that price discrimination is
a widespread tactic of flight ticket
sales hotel and apartment bugging
portals as well as car rental providers
people from different countries and IP
addresses get to see different prices so
you might be surprised how much you can
save on plane tickets or apartment
bookings with surf shark VPN now if you
guys still are convinced surf shark can
be used on as many devices as you like
even all of them at the same time no
other VPN allows this so if you're
diggin surf shark then for 47 dollars
and 76 cents which is a dollar
ninety-nine a month you guys can get a
two year plan and one additional month
for
free now curly is the best price for a
premium privacy protection service on
the entirety of the market so Mitch you
guys go check out the link in the
description make sure you guys check out
sir shark VPN and as far as the powers
of the Living Tribunal because it's so
incredibly powerful because he can do so
much it's really hard to boil down
everything that he's capable of in this
to a single list of powers because he
can basically do anything he wants he's
able to warp reality he possesses
omniscience and near omnipotence he's
able to summon other powerful cosmic
entities such as the in-betweener at
will The Living Tribunal was able to
turn the silver surfer into a God by
simply allowing the silver surfer to
touch the void that exists on the side
of living tribunals head where there is
no face The Living Tribunal is also able
to manipulate time and even make time
come to a standstill throughout the
entirety of the universe similarly he
can speed up time to the point of
accelerating the death of a son which on
his own is a process that would take
billions of years one of the most
impressive displays of the living
tribunals power occurred when his
judgments stopped the assembled Infinity
stones which as you probably know are
capable of altering the very fabric of
reality later he would render another
judgment that would return the stones
power to them and another of the Living
tribunals judgments he considers whether
to allow the Beyonder to retain his
omnipotence within his own universe
suggestion that he's able to take powers
away from omnipotent beings he decides
to allow the Beyonder to keep his power
but seals him inside of his own reality
so that he cannot interfere with
alternate universes in another instance
of a living tribunals judgment he must
decide whether to replace the 6160
universe with the ultimate universe he
decides against it but the fact that he
was even contemplating doing this shows
us how powerful he can be that he's able
to replace one universe with another he
was also able to absorb the protege a
being that had duplicated the tribunals
own power and a tendency usurped the one
above all and pretty much become the top
being in all of reality and so it's
widely believed that the Living Tribunal
is the second most powerful entity in
Marvel Comics with only the one above
all being more powerful than when Thanos
wheels the Infinity Gauntlet which gives
him insight into the inner workings of
the universe he confirms a tribunals
place as the second most powerful entity
in existence and because we know the
tribunal ranked so high on the power
hierarchy and that he can make and
unmake universes if he chooses to do so
we know the tribunal is well beyond
Omega level here's a funny thing though
like back when that whole Infinity
Gauntlet thing was made that was back
before like the beyonders showed up and
that was before
marquee of death here's my question how
does a marquee of death ranked next to
the Living Tribunal right like the
marquee of death was a guy who was
hopping and skipping through universes
and wiping them out with a wave of his
hand it was ridiculous how powerful he
is honestly I probably say the marquee
of death was equal to the power of the
Living Tribunal which then begs the
question why wasn't the Living Tribunal
invoked during the stories that involved
the marquee of death because plot device
that's why because the marquee of death
was a story that wanted to be told by
Marvel and it didn't make any sense to
bring The Living Tribunal in because
they didn't want to that's basically it
the Living Tribunal is what we in Marvel
Comics refer to as a plot device it's
basically a being that exists to serve
the purpose of wrapping up a story or
transitioning from one story to the next
and yes it sucks but that's usually just
the way it is that's the way Marvel
Comics works it doesn't always work
logically if there were some kind of
imbalance in the universe as a result of
the actions of some individual the
Living Tribunal would show up a lot more
often than it does and it would fix
things and that would basically be the
end of that but in order to be able to
tell some measure of an interesting
story the Living Tribunal is not invoked
which in reality the eluding tribunals
showing up and basically fixing
everything at the end of the marquee of
death story probably would have sucked
because do the way that story ended
wasn't legit dude I love the story of
the marquee of death if you don't know
who I'm talking about check the video
down in the description that dude is
broken do he is so Opie this insane he's
like any of the guns in truth he's like
the Prometheus lands introduced and
destiny to you on the first day do
crucible turn into a laser tag it was
the most fun ever
and then Bungie did what Bungie does and
screw up something awesome they
basically fixed it and it was like why
would you do that
just like take Prometheus lens out of
everything and then throw it into its
own crucible playlist and say here you
go guys you just go play the Prometheus
limbs playlist and just have fun with it
right like the religious winds is not in
crucible it's not in PvE like literally
you just can't use it in any anything
except for that one Christmas playlist
just like I play this all the time man
it was amazing it was it was like that
would be the coolest thing ever but
nonetheless the Living Tribunal is super
powerful is a very capable be however
it's kind of a misnomer to say it's the
second most powerful being in all of
Marvel Comics right because you've got
to be honors which obliterated the
Living Tribunal going toe-to-toe one
beyond a verse of the Living Tribunal
maybe if you're talking about prereq
Kombi honor from Secret Wars it was more
powerful than the Living Tribunal but
like if you're talking about
consistently appearing characters in
Marvel Comics with the exception of like
and leaving out like one offs right like
the beyonders from Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers the original Biondo
from Secret Wars one and two and kind of
Secret Wars three and the Fantastic Four
story the character of Protege who
exists
only in a six-issue story-arc if this is
what you're talking about like those
specialty characters that appear for a
really short amount of time didn't know
the Living Tribunal is not the most
powerful not the second most powerful
character to have ever appeared in the
history of mobile comics but in terms of
consistently appearing characters yes
it's just that powerful
it's kind of interesting right let the
Living Tribunal super powerful I would
say that the Phoenix force is probably
next to the Living Tribunal in terms of
power right so you've got like the one
above all and then under the one above
all you've got like the Phoenix force in
the Living Tribunal and then under them
you probably have oblivion and then that
you have the other cosmic entities and
so on I don't know I've got a model
power hierarchy but I feel like I should
make a new one based on all the
information that's come out now anyway
we've rambled long enough we've talked
long enough about nonsense that be said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb cork
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later purse
[Music]